MATT SULLIVAN: Welcome
to the "Developer Show."
I am Matt Sullivan,
and I am here
at DartConf with Emily Fortuna,
who works on the Dart team.
EMILY FORTUNA: Hello.
MATT SULLIVAN: Why don't you
tell us a little bit about what
you do on Dart?
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah, so
I'm a software engineer
on the Dart-to-JS team.
So I work on compiling
Dart to JavaScript.
And that is an interesting and
fun and challenging problem,
because Dart has different
semantics from JavaScript,
as you may be well aware.
And there's lots of
challenges in terms
of making the resulting
JavaScript code perform,
and making it small enough so
that download sizes don't take
too long, and making the
actual compilation process not
take too long.
MATT SULLIVAN: So Dart
2 is on the horizon.
How does it affect
what you're working on?
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah,
so we've been working
for the past year
pretty hard on keeping
the outside of
Dart-to-JS working
for all of our existing
customers with the old version
of Dart.
But on the inside,
working really
hard to do lots of engineering
to get ready for Dart 2.0.
And this involves strong mode.
And this will be super
exciting, because that
means that we can do a lot
more compiler optimizations,
because we can
trust those types.
And we can do better
type inference.
And so we can get a lot
better at determining
what code is used, what code
isn't, do better inlining.
It's going to be great.
MATT SULLIVAN: So
you're here at DartConf
to talk about Flutter
with a fabulous co-host.
What excites you about Flutter?
And why are you here
to talk about it?
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah, so I'm
super excited about Flutter,
because it's an
amazing tool that's
built with Dart that
allows people to develop
mobile applications and
run them on iOS and Android
with one code base, not having
to write the same logic twice.
And Dart is a really powerful
and concise programming
language to do that.
And Flutter is
really taking off.
Since we initially debuted
it at I/O last year,
we have a lot of
new improvements.
There's things like support
for any gifs or gifs,
depending on who
you're talking to.
And we've got a lot
of new plugin support.
There's things like support
for different location
APIs with the cell phones.
And I'm super
excited, because there
are-- we're getting a lot
of third-party contributions
from people on GitHub.
And this means
people are starting
to take a look at Flutter,
and using it, and contributing
back.
So I've been working on
reviewing those poll requests.
MATT SULLIVAN: Thank you,
Emily, for your time.
This has been the "Developer
Show" from Los Angeles
at DartConf.